The first property three criterion to consider is adequacy. That is,
the lower level implementation must be rich enough that each abstract state is
represented by a concrete state. State it precisely, for
each abstract invariant, if the invariant is true in a state.
Then there must exist a corresponding state in the implementation in which that
the corresponding concrete invariant is also true. And in logic, okay, for
every, every abstract state S, okay, if the abstract invariant is true for S,
then there must exist some state T down in the concrete. implementation. And
some, some, concrete invariant over that state T,
such that if you were to apply the retrieve function to the concrete state,
you would get the abstract state.